OK three boys aged 13, 15 and 16. All three chose to appear with fake names on this radio program. And the fake names they chose, ready, K-Rad, Mr. Wares, and Fred. Those first two names come out of the world of computer hacking and software piracy. It's Mr. Wares. That's Wares, as in wares, as in softwares, as in illegal softwares, pirated softwares. And as for Fred?
好的，三位男孩分别是13岁、15岁和16岁。这三个人都选择在广播节目中使用化名。他们选的化名是——听好了——K-Rad、Wares先生和Fred。前两个名字来自计算机黑客和软件盗版世界。这是“Wares先生”，即“Wares”，指“wares”，意为软件，也就是非法软件、盗版软件。至于Fred呢？
Why Fred? For no reason, man. There's gotta be someone else named Fred out there.
为什么叫Fred？没理由，伙计。外面肯定还有别人也叫Fred。
Anonymity was important given the kinds of things we were discussing, namely credit card fraud, computer hacking, and the nature of hell.
鉴于我们讨论的内容，即信用卡诈骗、计算机黑客行为以及地狱的本质，保持匿名很重要。
Well, from WBEZ in Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today on our program, how bad is bad enough to count? Act One, How Bad is Stealing $800? Act Two, a little radio experiment. We're all going to put on the lab coats and need protective goggles and hope you do the same.
大家好，这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台的《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们都会在节目中选定一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天节目的主题是：坏到什么程度才算坏？第一幕：偷窃800美元有多坏？第二幕：一个小小的广播实验。我们都要穿上实验服，戴上防护眼镜，希望你们也一样。
Act Three, How Bad is This Relationship? Act Four, How Bad is This Movie? We teach you a simple home test that anybody can do to determine if a movie is actually good or actually bad. Act Five, Creating Your Own Moral Code, the story of a teenager with the power to shut down your phone line or anyone else's, and how he decided to wield his power. Stay with us.
第三幕：这段关系有多坏？第四幕：这部电影有多坏？我们将教你一个任何人都能做的简单的家庭测试，来判断一部电影到底是好还是坏。第五幕：建立你自己的道德准则，一个有能力切断你或任何人电话线的少年的故事，以及他决定如何运用自己的权力。请继续收听。
Act One. So K-Rad, Mr. Wares, and Fred were trying to be criminals, but they were not too successful at it. They were in New York for a hacker's convention. Between sessions, I followed them to lunch at a McDonald's on Times Square. At first, Fred was going to pay for Mr. Wares and K-Rad.
第一幕。K-Rad、Wares先生和Fred曾试图成为罪犯，但并不太成功。他们在纽约参加黑客大会。在会议间隙，我跟着他们去时代广场的一家麦当劳吃午餐。起初，Fred打算请Wares先生和K-Rad吃。
What do you guys want?
你们想吃什么？
I want a number one meal.
我要一份一号套餐。
But Fred wasn't used to the downtown prices.
但Fred不习惯市中心的物价。
Oh my god, that's $5 man. You guys are chipping in. I can't pay for this.
天哪，那要5美元啊，伙计们。你们得平摊。我付不起这个钱。
I think it's safe to say that one sign that your criminal career is not going as well as you might want it to is if you have to worry about the prices at McDonald's. But K-Rad, Mr. Wares, and Fred were involved in very low level types of crimes. All the times involved computers. They pirated software. They scammed free CD-Rom games. They cheated one of the big online computer services out of a few hundred dollars in online time.
我想可以肯定地说，如果你的犯罪生涯需要为麦当劳的价格发愁，那就说明你的犯罪事业进展得不如你预期的那么顺利。但K-Rad、Wares先生和Fred参与的都是非常低级的犯罪。所有这些都涉及电脑。他们盗版软件。他们骗取免费的CD-ROM游戏。他们骗了某个大型在线计算机服务商几百美元的上网费。
All in all, they didn't steal very much, and they didn't steal very effectively, but stealing was the ideal. Here's a typical one of their scams. They called people at random and tried to get a calling card number or a credit card number out of them.
总而言之，他们偷得不多，手段也不高明，但偷窃是他们的理想。这是他们典型的诈骗手段之一。他们随机打电话给别人，试图从对方那里骗取电话卡号或信用卡号。
Basically the way it works is this. You call up somebody. You say, "This is the AT&T operator." The whole point is you have to sound like you're not calling somebody up with the intention of getting them. You have to sound like you've been sitting in this chair for 10 hours, and you want to go home.
基本上原理是这样的：你打电话给某人。你说：“这是AT&T接线员。”关键在于你的语气不能像是专门打电话去行骗的。你得听起来像是已经在椅子上坐了10个小时，现在只想回家的人。
So you have to go, "This is the AT&T operator. I have a collect call for Paul. Will you accept charges sir?" "Yeah, I'll accept charges." "All right, hold one one second." Then you tap on the keyboard. You say, "I'm sorry, you seem to have a restriction on your phone line. You can't accept collect calls to this line." And then they yell, and they go, "What do you mean I can't accept collect calls to my line. I've been getting collect calls to this line for 20 years."
所以你要说：“这是AT&T接线员。我有给Paul的对方付费电话。先生，您接受付费吗？”“是的，我接受。”“好的，请稍等。”然后你敲击键盘。你说：“抱歉，您的电话线路似乎有限制。此线路无法接听对方付费电话。”然后对方就会大喊大叫，说：“什么叫我的线路不能接听对方付费？我这20年来一直都在接对方付费电话。”
And then you have to go, "Sir, there's nothing I can do about it. My computer says you can't receive a collect call on this line. Would you like to try an alternate billing method?" And then they go, "What do you mean, alternate billing method?" "Well, you can bill it to your calling card or a major credit card." In which case, they'll proceed to either give you a calling card or a major credit card.
然后你得说：“先生，我对此无能为力。我的电脑显示该线路无法接听对方付费电话。您愿意尝试其他付费方式吗？”接着对方会问：“什么叫其他付费方式？”“嗯，您可以记在您的电话卡或主流信用卡上。”在这种情况下，他们就会提供电话卡或信用卡号。
And that of course is the idea behind the whole thing, to end up with a calling card number or a credit card number that they can use themselves. And, as you may suspect by now, there's just one problem with this little scam. That is, it does't work.
而这当然就是整个计划背后的意图，最终得到一个他们可以自己使用的电话卡号或信用卡号。而且，正如你现在可能猜到的那样，这个小骗局有一个问题。那就是，它根本不管用。
The reason it doesn't work is because a lot we had start yelling and saying, "What do you mean you can't bill it to my line. I want--"
它之所以不管用，是因为很多人会开始大喊大叫，说：“你什么意思，说我的线路不能记账？我想要……”
There are a lot of mad people.
有很多愤怒的人。
Because then they'll just say, oh, this is too much trouble. Forget it. I won't accept a collect call.
因为他们只会说，哦，这太麻烦了。算了，我不接受对方付费了。
The other scams these guys run don't do much better. They tried to hack their way into the mainframe system of a big computer retailer, but were caught and stopped before they got very far. They are such unaccomplished computer hackers that Fred himself was actually the victim of a hacker, twice. Somebody broke into his account on one computer bulletin board and then used his account and his electronic mail to visit some of the nether regions of the net.
这些人运行的其他骗局也好不到哪去。他们曾试图黑入一家大型计算机零售商的大型主机系统，但在还没走多远时就被发现并阻止了。他们是如此无能的黑客，以至于Fred本人曾两次成为黑客的受害者。有人入侵了他在某个计算机公告板上的账户，然后利用他的账户和电子邮件访问了网络上一些阴暗的角落。
Remember, you talked to the guy on IRC. There was this weird guy. This guy was going on all these sex channels, and he was wrecking my name and stuff. It was awful.
记得吗，你在IRC上和那个人聊过。有个怪人。那个人在所有色情频道上到处游荡，还在毁坏我的名声什么的。那太糟糕了。
You can't get pissed at him. I wouldn't get pissed at him because that would be entirely hypocritical. I've said that if anybody ever steals one of my credit cards, or ever hacks into my account or computer system, I will not care, and I will be perfectly allowable to that. To go and say, "I can't believe it. Somebody took my credit card."
你不能对他生气。我不会对他生气的，因为那样做会非常虚伪。我说过，如果有人偷了我的信用卡，或者黑进了我的账户或计算机系统，我不会在意的，那样做是完全允许的。再去说：“我真不敢相信。有人拿了我的信用卡。”
Yeah, I mean I wouldn't be like that.
是啊，我的意思是我不会那样的。
Well, so what if I did it to everyone else. I'm perfectly willing to let someone do that to me.
嗯，所以我对别人这么做又怎么样呢。我也完全愿意让别人对我做同样的事。
Over the summer was when they really started to get serious. Mostly it was what they call carding, getting other people's credit card numbers and then buying stuff on their credit cards. They met this adult who knew all about carding and who showed them some tricks. K-Rad and Fred ordered $1,600 in computer merchandise on somebody else's credit card, had it delivered to a neutral address, picked it up, sold half of the stuff for cash, kept the rest.
整个夏天是他们真正开始认真的时候。主要是他们所谓的“刷卡”，获取别人的信用卡号，然后用别人的信用卡买东西。他们遇到了一个成年人，那人很了解刷卡，并教了他们一些技巧。K-Rad和Fred用别人的信用卡订购了1600美元的计算机商品，送到一个中立地址，取货，卖掉一半换取现金，剩下自己留着。
Now one thing that's peculiar about this story is that these are rich kids. K-Rad and Fred live in a wealthy, upstate community. They attend one of the most expensive, prestigious private schools in the country. But they steal. Fred believes he has no choice. He wanted to get all the things the other kids at private school had, a microwave, a stereo. He just wanted to be the same as everybody else.
现在这个故事里有一个奇怪的地方，那就是这些孩子很有钱。K-Rad和Fred居住在一个富裕的北部社区。他们就读于全国最昂贵、最负盛名的私立学校之一。但他们偷东西。Fred认为他别无选择。他想得到私立学校其他孩子拥有的所有东西，比如微波炉、音响。他只是想和大家一样。
A skinny, young-looking 15, he is perpetually strapped for cash. He said his parents could not help him much with money right now because they'd just gone a half million dollars in debt buying a house. At one point, to get some cash, he sold the computer his parents had given him for school without ever telling them. He wanted to replace the computer as quickly as possible with the help of a stranger's credit card.
他15岁，瘦削，看起来很年轻，永远缺钱。他说他父母现在没法在钱上帮他太多，因为他们买房子欠了50万美元的债。有一次，为了弄点现金，他卖掉了父母给他买来上学用的电脑，却从没告诉他们。他想在陌生人的信用卡帮助下，尽快买回那台电脑。
I'm also pretty good at shoplifting, but my whole thing on that is it I will not steal anything if I have the money for it. And a lot of times, the store at my school, like the grill, I steal from that a lot. But I also give them $10 for no reason if I have the money because I feel bad about what I've stolen. And if I ever get the money so I didn't have to do this [BLEEP] anymore, then I'm not going to do it.
我在商店行窃方面也很在行，但我的原则是，如果我有钱，我就绝不会偷任何东西。很多时候，在我学校的商店，比如烧烤店，我经常在那偷东西。但如果我有钱的话，我也会无缘无故地给他们10美元，因为我觉得偷了东西很内疚。如果我哪天有了钱，不用再做这种[哔]事了，我就绝对不会再做了。
What's most striking about this is how Fred and the other boys, I think, really want to convince themselves that they are good, that they really do not harm anybody with what they're doing. Or if it does harm someone what they're doing, there's the reassuring thought that someday, somehow, they might make it up to the injured party.
最令人震惊的是Fred和其他男孩是如何真正想说服自己是好人的，他们觉得自己的行为并没有伤害任何人。或者如果他们的行为确实伤害了某人，那么还有一个令人宽慰的想法：总有一天，以某种方式，他们可能会补偿受害者。
As noble as this sounds, if I ever-- this is one thing that I absolutely guarantee that sounds like the biggest load of crap anyone could ever say. But if I am ever--
尽管这听起来很崇高，但如果我有朝一日——这是我绝对能保证的一件事，听起来简直是任何人能说的最胡扯的话。但如果我哪天……
We believe in you.
我们相信你。
No, no one should believe me. This is the biggest, I'm really good inside. If I ever find myself-- and I've made this vow to myself-- in a good enough financial situation, I will repay everything I have ever done now. I mean if I find myself making $2 million a year, I will send a $10,000 check to the company which I stole calling cards from. That is something I definitely want to do if I'm in the financial situation to do it.
不，谁都不该相信我。这是最扯的，我内心其实很好。如果我哪天——我对自己发过誓——处于良好的财务状况，我会偿还我现在所做的一切。我的意思是，如果我发现自己年入200万美元，我会给那些被我偷过电话卡的公司寄一张10000美元的支票。如果我财务状况允许，那绝对是我想要做的事。
K-Rad believes that the $1,600 they charged to a stranger's Visa card was a victimless crime, that the credit card owner would call Visa and have the charge removed from his bill. And that Visa figures a certain amount of fraud is just the cost of doing business.
K-Rad认为他们刷陌生人Visa卡的那1600美元是无受害者的犯罪，因为信用卡持有人会打电话给Visa，把这笔费用从账单中删掉。而且Visa认为一定数量的欺诈只是经营成本的一部分。
One thing that I've always said in all of my doing is that I will never ever do something that will severely hurt an individual person, OK. So, for example, if it involves-- I would never mug someone. I would never beat someone up for money. I'd never shoplift. Well, maybe I-- no, I wouldn't shoplift because that is hurting an individual person.
我在所有行为中一直说的一件事是，我永远不会做严重伤害个人的事，好吧。所以，例如，如果涉及——我绝不会抢劫别人。我绝不会为了钱打人。我绝不会去商店行窃。好吧，也许我——不，我不会去商店行窃，因为那是伤害个人。
I'm just going to stop the tape right here. This is just this amazing moment that I love captured on tape. He is struggling over this so much that you could actually hear him figure out his position on this as he speaks. Let me play this for you again.
我就在这里暂停录音带。这是我录音带里捕捉到的一个我非常喜欢的绝妙瞬间。他在这件事上纠结得厉害，以至于你可以听到他在说话时理清自己的立场。让我再放给你们听一遍。
I'd never shoplift. Well, maybe I-- no, I wouldn't shoplift because that is hurting the individual person.
我绝不会去商店行窃。好吧，也许我——不，我不会去商店行窃，因为那是伤害个人。
We headed of the McDonald's and back to the hotel where the computer hackers conventions was taking place. Without any prompting from me, Fred started talking again about this notion that he was only stealing because he absolutely had to.
我们前往麦当劳，然后回到黑客大会召开的酒店。没有我的任何引导，Fred又开始谈论那个想法：他偷东西只是因为他绝对需要。
I go to boarding school, and I don't have any money or anything. And I get really hungry and stuff. I have a fast metabolism. And seriously, I starve. And I lost 10 pounds in one week, and that's not good for someone who's really skinny like I am. And then a lot of it is just stuff I want. And yeah, I just really want to stress that in other ways, we're not bad people. We don't go around trying to screw off people in any way we can because we're not at all. I mean I do social work. I tutor kids. I do a lot of stuff which isn't necessarily evil and is more good. But sometimes, it's just like, I don't know man, I like doing it. I can't explain it.
我去寄宿学校，我没有钱什么的。我真的很饿。我新陈代谢快。说真的，我饿坏了。我一周瘦了10磅，这对像我这样真的很瘦的人来说不好。而且很多时候这只是我想要的东西。是的，我真的想强调，在其他方面，我们不是坏人。我们不会到处试图以任何方式欺负别人，因为我们根本不是那种人。我的意思是，我做社会工作。我辅导孩子。我做很多不一定邪恶，甚至是有益的事情。但有时候，就像，我不知道伙计，我就是喜欢这么做。我解释不了。
Well, talk about that part of it. What is the thrill of doing it?
好吧，谈谈那部分。做这件事的快感是什么？
That was the reason I started carding, the thrill of going-- we went in there. It was like Mission Impossible . We went in. We had gloves on and stuff and we picked it up. We had it all worked out. We were connected. We had lookouts and stuff. And it's just a lot of fun. You're doing stuff that is not exactly legal, not legal all, and it's fun.
这就是我开始刷卡的原因，那种刺激感——我们进去了。就像《碟中谍》。我们进去了。我们戴着手套什么的，然后取了货。我们计划得万无一失。我们联系好了。我们有放哨的人什么的。这真的很有趣。你在做一些并不完全合法，甚至根本不合法的事情，这很有趣。
By this point, we were back in the hotel lobby. We took the elevators up to the hackers convention. K-Rad said that real hackers don't do what he and Fred had done. Real hackers don't use their skills for personal gain. They don't steal credit card numbers. They don't defraud people. Real hackers, he said, break into computers just to see if they can do it.
此时，我们回到了酒店大堂。我们乘电梯去了黑客大会。K-Rad说，真正的黑客不会做他和Fred做过的那种事。真正的黑客不会利用他们的技能谋取私利。他们不会窃取信用卡号。他们不会欺诈他人。他说，真正的黑客侵入电脑只是为了看看自己能不能做到。
We moved to a corner of the hallway where we wouldn't be overheard by the real hackers. K-Rad said that they'd never really talked with anybody about their illegal activities this much ever before.
我们走到走廊的一个角落，以免被真正的黑客听到。K-Rad说，他们以前从未和任何人谈论过这么多关于他们非法活动的事。
The most thing I'm worried about is I'm actually starting, for the first time, to say this all out loud, everything I've done. And suddenly, it doesn't sound as hacker much anymore. And I've known that, ever since I moved into doing maybe some credit card thing. That's why I'm, in fact, even considering giving up on doing all the carding and stuff like that. Seriously I am.
我最担心的是，我实际上是第一次把这一切都大声说出来，我所做的一切。突然间，这听起来就不再那么像黑客行为了。从我开始搞信用卡那一刻起，我就意识到了。这就是为什么事实上，我甚至在考虑放弃所有的刷卡之类的行为。说真的，我是认真的。
Fred shot him a look. If he were serious and they did quit carding, Fred would never get a computer to replace his old one.
Fred瞪了他一眼。如果他是认真的，而他们真的停止刷卡，Fred就永远没法买台新电脑替换旧的了。
What about my computer?
那我的电脑怎么办？
What? Your computer will come first.
什么？你的电脑会优先考虑。
Jesus Christ, man. I'm going to get a gun and shoot you.
天哪，伙计。我要拿把枪毙了你。
All right, after your computer.
好吧，在你电脑之后。
The thing about a bad conscience is that it splits you in half. Fred said that he had two different modes, that was the word he used, modes. Sometimes he would think about what he and K-Rad were doing, and he knew it was wrong. But mostly, he tried not to think about it.
坏良心的事就是把你一分为二。Fred说他有两种不同的模式，那是他使用的词，模式。有时他会思考他和K-Rad在做什么，他知道那是错的。但大多数时候，他试图不去想它。
I try to limit that as much as possible because I generally feel crappy when I do that. And the rest of the time, I try to forget that I do that and just carry on with my basic life. And a lot of times when I think about it, my worst fear is that I'm going to end up going to hell for doing this. And that's my worst fear.
我尽量限制这种想法，因为我这样做时通常感觉很糟糕。其余时间，我试图忘记我做过的事，继续我的基本生活。很多时候当我想到它时，我最大的恐惧就是我会因为做这些事而下地狱。那是我的最大恐惧。
Do you believe in hell?
你相信地狱吗？
Yeah, I do.
是的，我相信。
And you think you can go to hell for getting a computer on somebody else's credit card?
你认为你会因为用别人的信用卡买电脑而下地狱吗？
I don't know. I hope not. I really hope not. It's always been my biggest fear. That's why I'm afraid of dying. I'm afraid if there's something I've done which is just the straw on the camel's back, that's going to be what's going to  do it.
我不知道。我希望不会。我真的希望不会。那一直是我最大的恐惧。这就是为什么我害怕死亡。我害怕如果我做过的事是压垮骆驼的最后一根稻草，那就会是我最终的下场。
How big is this worry? Will this keep you up at night?
这种担心有多大？会让你晚上睡不着吗？
Yeah, maybe for a couple minutes. And then I just put it out of my mind.
是的，也许会持续几分钟。然后我就把它抛到脑后了。
His share of the carding profits was $800. I told him that from an adult's perspective, it did not seem like a lot of money. I didn't think you could do eternity in hell for just $800. And as soon as I said this, I regretted it. Fred's body language changed completely. It was just this moment. It was like I was calling him a little kid, saying he was ridiculous to worry about something so small. And he was offended and got quieter and just withdrew.
他那份刷卡利润是800美元。我告诉他，从成年人的角度来看，这看起来并不算多。我不认为你可以为了区区800美元在永恒的地狱中度过。而我刚说完这话，我就后悔了。Fred的肢体语言完全变了。就在那一瞬间。感觉就像我叫他小孩子，说他为这么小的事担忧是很可笑的。他被冒犯了，变得更安静，只是退缩了。
Then Mr. Wares spoke up. He said that maybe by adult standards this wasn't much money, but to them, it was a lot of money. It was plenty enough to count. When is hell a possibility? Whenever you think it is, it is. More on this when our program continues.
然后Wares先生插话了。他说，也许按成年人的标准，这不是多少钱，但对他们来说，这可是不少钱。这足够算数了。地狱什么时候成为可能？只要你觉得它是，它就是。节目继续后还有更多相关内容。
Act Two, Golden Peacock. For this act, we thought we'd try a little radio experiment. I told a Chicago playwright named Jeff Dorchen about the three boys in our first story today, what they said about sin and their own relative badness in this world. And he created a very brief radio play picking up where they left off. Here's what he came up with.
第二幕，金孔雀。为了这一幕，我们想尝试一个小小的广播实验。我向一位名叫Jeff Dorchen的芝加哥剧作家讲述了今天第一个故事里的三个男孩，关于他们对罪恶的看法以及他们在世界上相对的邪恶程度。他创作了一个非常简短的广播剧，从他们停下的地方继续展开。这是他的作品。
I'll call.
我跟。
Me too.
我也是。
Three tens.
三个十。
Full house, aces and eights.
满堂红，A和八。
What do you got, kid?
你有什么，孩子？
Four diamonds.
四张方块。
You got nothing.
你什么都没有。
See if you had some where the numbers matched, or if they were in order and there were five of them, but that, what you have there, that's nothing.
你看，如果你有一些数字匹配的牌，或者它们是顺子且有五张，但那个，你有的那个，那什么都不是。
My grandpa used to call that a kangaroo straight.
我爷爷以前管那叫“袋鼠顺子”。
My dad used to call it a Klondike.
我爸以前管那叫“克朗代克”。
Klondike wins the game.
克朗代克赢了。
No, Klondike doesn't win the game. Peter wins the game. Full house wins.
不，克朗代克没赢。Peter赢了。满堂红赢了。
I hate you, Peter.
我恨你，Peter。
I don't blame you.
我不怪你。
[WAILING GRANDMOTHER]
[祖母的哀嚎]
Grandmother, be careful. Grazie.
祖母，小心点。谢谢。
My deal. Straight five card draw.
我发牌。五张抽牌顺子。
Anything wild?
有万能牌吗？
No.
没有。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
Shut up.
闭嘴。
Ow, watch it with those cards man.
噢，拿牌小心点，伙计。
Sorry.
抱歉。
What's your problem today?
你今天怎么了？
He has sinned.
他犯了罪。
Yes I have. How did you know?
是的，我犯了。你怎么知道的？
Your eyes, they are the eyes of an accused man, furtive, alert. The eyes of a nervous beast who, once a lover of gambols and cheeks and standard metals, has been driven to nocturnal skulking by the pursuit of a relentless predator.
你的眼睛，那是被告的眼睛，鬼鬼祟祟，警觉。像是一头紧张的野兽，曾经热爱嬉戏、腮红和标准金属，现在却被无情的捕食者追逐而被迫夜间潜行。
He's got you there. 10,000 lira.
他说得对。1万里拉。
Call.
跟。
Call. Caleb, do you believe in sin?
跟。Caleb，你相信罪吗？
Hell no, I believe in damnation though.
见鬼，我不信。不过我相信诅咒。
How can you believe in damnation but not sin?
你怎么能相信诅咒却不相信罪呢？
Predestiny. Take me, I was born damned. I'm cowardly, petty intolerant, lazy, and just generally destructive. I knew I was damned the first time I heard the word.
宿命。就拿我来说，我生来就被诅咒了。我胆小、琐碎、不宽容、懒惰，而且总的来说是有破坏性的。我在第一次听到那个词时就知道我被诅咒了。
Your Calvinism relieves you of the responsibility for improving yourself.
你的加尔文主义使你免于承担自我完善的责任。
Shut up kid.
闭嘴，孩子。
What are you doing?
你在干什么？
It's all right, GI Joe, I am strong.
没事，特种部队，我很强。
Yeah Pete, the kid can take it. Now give me three.
是啊Pete，这孩子能承受。现在给我三张。
How many, Dondi?
几张，Dondi？
Four.
四张。
You can't have four. The most you can have is three.
你不能拿四张。最多只能拿三张。
OK, I'll take two.
好吧，我要两张。
And two for the dealer.
发牌员两张。
5,000.
5000。
Call.
跟。
Call. What do you have?
跟。你有什么？
Pair of nines. Dondi?
一对九。Dondi呢？
Three onions.
三个洋葱。
Those are spades, not onions. And you're supposed to match the numbers, not the suit, you little spaghetti sucker.
那是黑桃，不是洋葱。而且你应该匹配数字，不是花色，你这个吃意大利面的小混蛋。
I have a Klondike.
我有一个克朗代克。
[WAILING GRANDMOTHER]
[祖母的哀嚎]
You have garbage. How many times do we have to go through this? It's like rolling a boulder up a hill just to have it roll back down again over and over and over.
你那是垃圾。我们要经历多少次这种事？就像把巨石推上山，结果它又滚下来，周而复始。
I will not make the mistake again, sahib.
我不会再犯同样的错误了，长官。
Don't call me sahib. Peter, what do you have? Pair of jacks, all right. Pair of jacks takes it. All right, seven card stud poker, one-eyed royalty, red deuces, nines and all odd-numbered clubs are wild.
别叫我长官。Peter，你有什么？一对J，好吧。一对J赢了。好吧，七张牌梭哈，单眼王牌，红色二，九和所有奇数黑桃都是万能牌。
What do you guys think the worse sin is, murder?
你们觉得最严重的罪是什么，谋杀吗？
Betrayal.
背叛。
Why do you say that?
为什么这么说？
At the center of the ninth and innermost frozen circle of hell, Lucifer devours Judas eternally.
在地狱第九层也是最内层的冰冻圆圈中心，路西法永恒地吞噬着犹大。
Really?
真的吗？
That's what they say. 1 million lira.
他们是这么说的。100万里拉。
I'll see that, and raise you one.
我跟，再加一百万。
Call.
跟。
I'm there.
我也跟。
What do you got?
你有什么？
Seven aces.
七个A。
Me too.
我也一样。
So do I. All right, so there are a few too many wild cards. Let's hold the pot over.
我也是。好吧，万能牌太多了。把筹码留着吧。
OK. Peter.
好吧。Peter。
Oh, sure, leave it over.
哦，当然，留着吧。
[WAILING GRANDMOTHER]
[祖母的哀嚎]
Do you think a sin is worse if say you-- for example you betray somebody. Then suppose you don't feel any remorse, does that make it worse?
你觉得罪恶是否更严重，比如你——举个例子，你背叛了某人。然后假设你没有任何悔意，那会让罪恶更严重吗？
Of course. Gentlemen, the game is Chicago low. Ace, no face, sevens, follow the queen.
当然。先生们，玩芝加哥低牌。A，无花牌，七，跟红桃皇后。
Wait a second, Dondi. Caleb, could I talk to alone for a second? Over there by the window?
等一下，Dondi。Caleb，我能和你单独谈谈吗？就在窗边？
Sure Pete.
没问题Pete。
I will go fetch us some delicious ginger ale.
我去给我们拿点好喝的姜汁汽水。
Good idea. What is it, Pete? You think the kid's trying to hustle us?
好主意。怎么了，Pete？你觉得那孩子在坑我们吗？
No, I just wanted to talk. That's all.
不，我只是想聊聊。就这样。
What's a matter?
怎么了？
Nothing, just I'm afraid of going to hell.
没什么，我只是害怕下地狱。
What? Why?
什么？为什么？
I just don't think I'm a very good person.
我只是觉得我不是个好人。
That's ridiculous, Pete. You're a very nice guy. You write letters. I never write letters.
那太荒谬了，Pete。你是个很好的人。你会写信。我从来不写信。
Yeah, but what if you do something bad? How bad does it have to be? I mean if-- do you have to-- if you feel like it's bad enough to damn you, are you damned? I mean if you don't feel any remorse?
是啊，但如果你做了坏事呢？到底要坏到什么程度？我的意思是如果——你必须要——如果你觉得这已经坏到足以诅咒你，你就被诅咒了吗？我的意思是如果你没有悔意呢？
Is that it? You betrayed somebody and then didn't feel any remorse? Is that what all those pregnant pauses during the poker banter were about?
是这样吗？你背叛了某人却没有悔意？所有那些扑克闲聊时的沉默是为了这个吗？
Well.
嗯。
How can you say you don't have any remorse when you're practically tearing your hair out worrying about going to hell?
当你几乎快要把头发扯下来担心下地狱的时候，怎么能说你没有悔意呢？
But being afraid of punishment isn't the same as remorse. Remorse is truly feeling apologetic for what you've done, not just worrying about punished for it.
但害怕惩罚和悔意是不一样的。悔意是真心为自己的所作所为感到抱歉，而不是仅仅担心因此受到惩罚。
And you don't feel sorry at all?
而且你一点也不觉得抱歉吗？
No.
不。
Even though you recognize that what you did was wrong?
即使你认识到你做的是错的？
That's right.
没错。
You know Pete, you're a very complex guy.
你知道Pete，你是个非常复杂的人。
Thank you.
谢谢。
They when to a sea in Sieve, they did. In a Sieve they went to sea. In spite of all their friends could say, on a winter's morn, on a stormy day, in a Sieve they went to sea.
他们乘着筛子去出海，真的。他们乘着筛子去出海。尽管朋友们怎么说，在一个冬天的早晨，在一个暴风雨的日子，他们乘着筛子去出海。
Dondi, what's with the old lady?
Dondi，那个老太太怎么了？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] is causing her to recite "The Jumblies" by Edward Lear.
[听不清] 让她开始背诵Edward Lear的《Jumblies》。
Well shut her up, will you? I can hardly hear myself think.
让她闭嘴行吗？我连自己的思考声都听不见了。
Shut up, Grandmother.
闭嘴，祖母。
I mean what am I doing here? Who are these strange people? I don't remember deciding to come to Italy. What am I doing in Italy?
我的意思是，我在这里干什么？这些奇怪的人是谁？我不记得我决定来意大利了。我在意大利干什么？
Maybe to see the Pope.
也许是为了见教皇。
Just last week I was in France in Rouen, the town where Joan of Arc was burned at the stake. And I was visiting the tower where she was held before her execution. And I was thinking about writing a letter, you know apologizing, a letter apologizing to the injured party. I was looking down from the highest window in the tower.
就在上周，我在法国的鲁昂，圣女贞德被火刑的那个镇子。我在参观她被处决前关押的塔。我在想写一封信，你知道，道歉，一封向受害者道歉的信。我当时正从塔最高的窗户往下看。
And just how you do-- you know, you try to tap into the place in yourself where you have truly apologetic feelings because you want to be sincere. You don't want the letter to sound phony. Except I realized, I discovered that there was no such place in myself, that where that place should have been, there was just an empty hole. And it was frightening. It was like staring into the abyss.
你知道，你试着去挖掘内心深处那些真正抱歉的情绪，因为你想真诚点。你不希望那封信听起来虚伪。但我意识到，我发现自己内心深处根本没有那样的地方，那个地方原本应该存在的位置，只有一个空洞。这太可怕了。就像凝视深渊一样。
Go see the Pope. Ask for absolution.
去见教皇吧。请求赦免。
But you have to be repentant. I'm not repentant.
但你必须诚心忏悔。我没有忏悔。
You could just act repentant. That's what ritual is all about, going through the motions.
你可以装作忏悔。仪式不就是那样吗，走个过场。
No, I'd have to be truly sorry in my heart or it wouldn't save me.
不，我必须发自内心地真诚悔改，否则我得救不了。
That is a very rigid attitude.
那是种非常死板的态度。
What do you mean? I can't just pretend to have remorse.
什么意思？我不能只是假装有悔意。
You haven't even tried. I mean the Pope is a very near-sighted, distracted old man. If you buried your hands in your hands and pretended to sob, I'm sure he'd buy it.
你甚至没试过。我的意思是教皇是个视力不好、容易走神的老人。如果你把脸埋在手里假装哭泣，我相信他会相信的。
It's not a question of fooling the Pope.
这不是糊弄教皇的问题。
[GRANDMOTHER WAILING]
[祖母的哀嚎]
You know, I'm starting to think that you don't really want to help yourself.
你知道，我开始觉得你根本不想自救。
How did I get here? Why are we playing poker in Italy with a demonic little boy whose grandmother is dying in the next room?
我是怎么到这儿的？为什么我们要在意大利打扑克，旁边还有一个邪恶的小男孩，他祖母在隔壁房间垂死？
[PEACOCK NOISE]
[孔雀叫声]
What was that?
那是什么？
A peacock.
孔雀。
What's that a symbol of?
那象征着什么？
Pride. Look, there it is the middle of the cemetery.
骄傲。看，就在那儿，墓地的中央。
[PEACOCK NOISE]
[孔雀叫声]
It's golden. A golden peacock in the middle of a graveyard. I wonder what it means.
它是金色的。墓地中间有一只金孔雀。不知道那意味着什么。
My advice is that you come up with the most positive interpretation you can.
我的建议是，你得想出尽可能积极的解释。
We're out of ginger ale. I can only offer you root beer.
姜汁汽水喝完了。我只能给你树根啤酒。
Well, that's all right.
好吧，没问题。
All right, gentleman. The game is--
好了，先生们。这个游戏是——
We know what the game is you little pistachio masher.
我们知道是什么游戏，你这个小开心果捣碎机。
Who dealt this mess?
谁发的牌？
Don't give me that bluffing baloney. You've got a possible straight flush and onions.
别跟我玩虚张声势那套。你可能有一手顺子同花加洋葱。
Do not mention onions, sahib. My grandfather was killed by El Duce.
别提洋葱，长官。我祖父是被墨索里尼杀害的。
Don't call me sahib.
别叫我长官。
Talk is cheap, gentlemen. 2 million lira.
言语是廉价的，先生们。200万里拉。
[PEACOCK NOISES]
[孔雀叫声]
Well, "The Golden Peacock" was written by Jeff Dorchen. Jeff also played Caleb. Peter Handler played Lisa. Lisa [? Stoddard ?] played Dondi. And I played the dying grandmother. Jeff Dorchen has a new play here in Chicago called Arrogant Living.
嗯，《金孔雀》是由Jeff Dorchen编写的。Jeff也饰演了Caleb。Peter Handler饰演Lisa。Lisa [? Stoddard ?]饰演Dondi。我饰演了那位垂死的祖母。Jeff Dorchen在芝加哥有一部新剧叫《傲慢的生活》。
Act Three, How Bad is This Relationship? Well, most of us have probably been in some relationship where it got to the point where you just had to look at it and say, all right, here are the things between us that are good. These are the other things that are bad, not so good. Is this relationship bad enough that the two of us should call it quits? Is it bad enough to count?
第三幕，这段关系有多坏？好吧，我们大多数人可能都经历过某种关系，它发展到你不得不正视它并说：好吧，这是我们之间好的地方。这些是其他坏的、不太好的地方。这段关系坏到我们两人该分道扬镳了吗？坏到什么程度才算坏？
Now on dates, it's different. On a date, things can be going well, and then suddenly turn around on a dime. In one sentence, it can go from good to bad. The other person says one thing, and you just think suddenly, oh, well this is going nowhere.
现在约会的话，情况就不同了。约会时，事情可以进行得很顺利，然后突然急转直下。一句话，它就可能从好变坏。对方说了一件事，你就突然觉得，噢，这没戏了。
This experience is so common that you could just walk up to somebody on the street, and they'll tell you one of these stories.
这种经历太常见了，你甚至可以在街上随便拦个人，他们都能告诉你一个这样的故事。
I should have known the relationship was doomed when on the first date-- he did order an amazing bottle of wine, so I was excited about that. But then when it got time to start with appetizers, he ordered the aspergas and shrooms. And that's when I found out that he couldn't just talk like a normal person. Everything-- aspergas is asparagus. Shrooms was mushrooms. He was never at home. He was at his hacienda. And if he wanted to go get a drink, it would be cock-a-tail. Enough said, I think.
我早该知道这段关系注定失败，因为在第一次约会时——他点了一瓶很棒的红酒，所以我当时很兴奋。但当开始吃前菜时，他点了芦笋和蘑菇。就在那时我发现他不能像正常人那样说话。所有东西——“aspergas”就是芦笋，“shrooms”就是蘑菇。他从不在家。他是在他的“hacienda”（庄园）。如果他想去喝一杯，那会是“cock-a-tail”（鸡尾酒）。我想，不用多说了。
Well, I was on a date, and I was going to dinner. And me and this girl, we're talking over dinner. And she asked me how my family was. I said that my older sister was married and just had a kid. And then I mentioned that my parents and my sister weren't getting along too well because she didn't get the kid baptized. And then she said, well why not? Doesn't your sister realize that your kid is going to burn in the fires of hell if she doesn't get her kid baptized? And that told me that maybe this isn't going to work out too well.
我在约会，去吃晚餐。我和那个女孩在吃晚饭时聊天。她问我家人怎么样。我说我姐姐结婚了，刚生了个孩子。然后我提到我父母和我姐姐相处得不太好，因为她没有给孩子洗礼。然后她说，嗯，为什么不呢？你姐姐难道不知道如果她不给她孩子洗礼，那孩子会在地狱的烈火中燃烧吗？那让我明白这段关系可能行不通。
The only thing that really bothers me is when every time it's time to go out on a date-- and at the end of the date, she's asking, "Now are you paying for it?" That's it.
唯一真正困扰我的是，每次该去约会的时候——在约会结束时，她会问：“现在是你买单吗？”就这样。
So we're sitting at the bar, and we're having drinks. And we're going over each other's history, what do you do? And he asked me what I did before I had my job now, and I said, oh well you know, I worked in Berkeley. I worked at one of these lefty research institutes, and I wrote papers for them. And he's like, "Lefty? You mean left handed?" And I was like, check.
所以我们坐在酒吧里喝酒。我们在回顾彼此的历史，你是做什么的？他问我在做这份工作之前是干什么的，我说，噢，你知道，我在伯克利工作。我在一个左派研究所工作，为他们写论文。他是那种，“左派？你是说左撇子吗？”我当时就想，好吧。
Talking very much. A lot of conversation and you are not involved. A lot of their life story, and you didn't ask for it. I mean so much conversation where it's like Charlie Brown. It's just to a point it gets, blah, blah, blah. What did you say? Oh. Blah, blah, blah. Basically, that's it.
说得太多了。谈话很多，而你并没有参与。很多他们的人生故事，而你根本没问。我的意思是谈话多到像是查理·布朗。它只是到了一个地步，blah, blah, blah。你说什么？哦。Blah, blah, blah。基本上就是这样。
This guy calls, and he comes to pick me up. He was very nice. I have to say I told him that I didn't know anything about Cincinnati, and he brought this architectural guide. We drove around and he showed me all of these historic landmark buildings that were very beautiful. And then he started driving around in these other neighborhoods and saying, "Well, I used to own that building but I sold it."
这家伙打电话来，他来接我。他真的很不错。我不得不说，我告诉他我对辛辛那提一无所知，他就带了一本建筑指南。我们开车四处转，他向我展示了所有那些非常漂亮的历史地标建筑。然后他开始开车去其他社区，说：“嗯，那栋楼我曾经拥有过，但我卖了。”
And I didn't really know what to say. I mean you're on a first date with someone. You don't really want to find out about their land holdings. So I just was polite, nodding, and we were driving around. And he points out another building. "Well, we own that one. And now we own this over here." And a lot of them were substandard housing. And then we drove by this other apartment complex, and he said, "Yeah, we had to put someone out of their apartment in that building on Christmas Eve. It was terrible." And I realized he was a slum lord.
我真的不知道该说什么。我的意思是这是和某人第一次约会。你真的不想知道他们的地产持股情况。所以我只是很有礼貌地点头，我们开车转悠。他又指了另一栋楼。“嗯，那个是我们拥有的。现在那边那个也是我们的。”很多都是不合标准的住房。然后我们开车经过另一个公寓群，他说：“是啊，我们不得不在圣诞节前夕把人赶出那栋楼的公寓。这太糟糕了。”我意识到他是个贫民窟房东。
We sit down to eat. And because of the way my kitchen is, we are eating in the living room. Because of the way my living room is, we're eating on the floor. And eating, eating, everything's going fine, I think. And midway through dinner, she drops her fork on her plate, clank. And I look up, and I'm wondering if something's gone wrong. And she says, "Why haven't you kissed me yet?"
我们坐下来吃东西。由于我厨房的原因，我们在客厅吃。由于我客厅的原因，我们在地板上吃。吃啊吃，一切都很顺利，我想。晚餐中间，她把叉子扔在盘子上，当啷一声。我抬头看，想知道出了什么事。她说：“你为什么还没吻我？”
So I kiss. And we kiss, kiss, kiss. And the kissing is going fine. There's no problem with the kissing. 10 minutes into kissing, again pulls back, starts to cry. And she says, "Don't you think it's sad that everyone else can fall in love and people like us just can't?" Well, what do you do at that point?
所以我吻了。我们吻啊吻，吻得很顺利。接吻没问题。吻了10分钟后，她又退缩了，开始哭。她说：“你不觉得每个人都能坠入爱河，而像我们这样的人就是不能，这很可悲吗？”好吧，这时候你该怎么办？
Act Four, How Bad is That Movie? Well, in this program, in which we ask the question how bad is bad enough to count, we offer this now as a public service to people everywhere who disagree about movies. So many movies are mediocre that the entire question of movies is just ripe for how bad is bad enough to count. So many movies seem to straddle or even obliterate the line between good and bad.
第四幕，这部电影有多坏？在这个节目中，我们问了一个问题：坏到什么程度才算坏？我们现在以此作为公共服务，提供给那些对电影评价不一的人们。太多的电影是平庸的，以至于电影是否坏到某种程度本身就成了一个问题。太多的电影似乎横跨，甚至抹去了好与坏的界限。
But we heard about a guy who had a simple, portable system to divide the wheat from the chaff. This test was invented by one Howard Rabinowitz of San Francisco, not a professional movie critic. He says to determine whether a movie is in fact good, you simply have to ask the question--
但我们听说一个人有一套简单、便携的系统可以将小麦从糠中分离出来。这个测试是由旧金山的Howard Rabinowitz发明的，他不是专业影评人。他说要确定一部电影实际上是好还是坏，你只需要问一个问题——
Is it better or worse than The Truth About Cats and Dogs? Because I take The Truth About Cats and Dogs as the absolute midpoint.
它比《关于猫狗的真相》更好还是更差？因为我把《关于猫狗的真相》作为绝对的中点。
That is the midpoint between good and bad, great and unwatchable. The Truth About Cats and Dogs, you may recall, is the mediocre romantic comedy in which Janeane Garofalo is good, Uma Thurman is bad, and a dog is on roller skates. It stands at the crossroads. It stands at the dividing line. And it's easy to use. Witness a typical movie-going night for Howard and his boyfriend.
那是好与坏、伟大与无法观看之间的中点。你可能还记得，《关于猫狗的真相》是一部平庸的浪漫喜剧，Janeane Garofalo演得好，Uma Thurman演得差，还有一只穿着溜冰鞋的狗。它处在十字路口。它处在分界线上。而且很容易使用。见证Howard和他男朋友一次典型的观影之夜。
We saw Chasing Amy , which a lot of people have liked and have said good things about. And we definitely agreed that it paled in comparison to The Truth About Cats and Dogs , which doesn't really bode well for the movie.
我们看了《猜·情·寻》，很多人喜欢并评价很高。我们一致认为它与《关于猫狗的真相》相比显得苍白无力，这对这部电影来说真的不是什么好兆头。
Let me just run a couple of recent movies by you and ask how they rate on The Truth About Cats and Dogs scale. LA Confidential , have you seen it?
让我拿几部近期的电影给你参考，问问它们在《关于猫狗的真相》量表上的评级。《洛城机密》，你看过吗？
I have. I think it's definitely above The Truth About Cats and Dogs line.
看过。我觉得它绝对在《关于猫狗的真相》这条线之上。
Far above?
高出很多吗？
Well, it might be helpful to say The Truth About Cats and Dogs is the midpoint. Then there's a tier of about-- I mean I don't want to get too specific-- but say, 37.5% of the rest of the movies that are made are in that realm of good, pretty good to good to very good. And I would say it falls on that shelf. It doesn't climb above into the great movies.
嗯，说《关于猫狗的真相》是中点可能更有帮助。然后还有一个层级——我不想说得太具体——但比如，剩下的37.5%的电影处于好、相当好到很好这一区间。我会说它落在那个档次。它还没有攀升到伟大电影的高度。
Another recent move, In the Company of Men.
另一部近期的电影，《男人最痛》。
Yeah, I would have to put that in just slightly above The Truth About Cats and Dogs unfortunately. If they had had one or two animals on roller skates, it could have been a different story.
是的，不幸的是，我不得不把它放在《关于猫狗的真相》上方一点点。如果他们有哪怕一两只穿着溜冰鞋的动物，情况可能会完全不同。
Friends, you heard it here first. Things that can make our lives easier, the metric system, Esperanto, The Truth About Cats and Dogs. Well, coming up, one man's wild Wild West, Catholics and their special problems, and does absolute power corrupt absolutely? That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
朋友们，你们在这里第一次听到了。能让我们生活更轻松的东西：公制系统、世界语、《关于猫狗的真相》。好吧，接下来，一个人的狂野西部，天主教徒和他们的特殊问题，绝对的权力是否会绝对导致腐败？节目继续后，国际公共广播电台将在几分钟内为你揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, how bad is bad enough to count? And before we go any further, I'd like to just make the case that Catholics have a special burden when it comes to this question.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。每周我们都会在节目中选定一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目主题是：坏到什么程度才算坏？在深入探讨之前，我想说天主教徒在面对这个问题时确实背负着特殊的负担。
Oh my god yes. I've always loved how Protestants can go sashay through life not really wanting to know whether something is really a big sin or just a little sin.
天哪，是的。我一直很喜欢新教徒可以随心所欲地生活，而不用真的想知道某件事到底是大罪还是小罪。
This is Jim Nelson, who was raised outside of Washington DC, where he attended DeMatha Catholic School for boys where he remembers many discussions in religion class over the difference between big sins and little sins. In 11th grade, for example, a heated, and surprisingly ambiguous discussion over how bad is masturbation. Church doctrine, he was told, said it was a cardinal said, meaning you'd go to hell for that.
这是Jim Nelson，他在华盛顿特区郊外长大，就读于DeMatha男子天主教学校，他记得在宗教课上经常讨论大罪和小罪的区别。例如，在11年级，关于手淫有多坏有过一场激烈且极其模糊的讨论。他被告知，教会教义说这是大罪，意味着你会因此下地狱。
But the living church, his teacher said, was much more lenient. Perhaps, current theologians said, it was just a venial sin, meaning bad, very bad of course, but you won't actually go to hell. The ambiguity drove Jim crazy. Which was it? Which was it, he says. He just had to know. He can still get worked up over it.
但他的老师说，现实中的教会要宽容得多。现在的神学家说，也许这只是轻罪，意味着虽然很坏、当然很坏，但你不会真的下地狱。这种模糊性让Jim抓狂。到底是哪个？到底是哪个？他说。他必须知道。他现在还能为此感到激动。
And if it isn't a cardinal sin, and if nobody-- if none of the priests believe that it is a cardinal sin-- then let's update the records. You know what I mean?
如果这不是大罪，如果没人——如果没有牧师认为这是大罪——那就更新记录吧。你明白我的意思吗？
Yeah, let's get everything in order question.
是的，整理一下，问题。
Let's just get everything in order. Let's be on the same page.
让我们把一切理顺。让我们在同一页面上。
Let's get organized here fellows.
各位，让我们组织起来。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Looking back, what do you make out of the entire endeavor of this, of trying to define well OK, here's the line. Here's the line that gets you into hell.
回顾过去，你如何看待试图定义“好吧，这是界限。这是让你下地狱的界限”这一整个努力？
I think it still sticks with me. That's the hard part about it.
我想它仍然困扰着我。这是最困难的部分。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And this is the vexing thing he says, that although he no longer is a practicing Catholic, he no longer believes in heaven and hell, he still finds himself asking, how bad is this? Cardinal sin? Venial sin? Is this bad enough to count. For instance, just last week, talking his way out of jury duty. Big sin or little sin? Not responding to email within 24 hours. Little sin, he says, but big enough that he lies to the people who write him the email, which of course is a big sin. But he figures not as big, and not as bad, as hurting the peoples' feelings by not responding quickly. Then there's the whole returning phone calls thing, returning them right away. If you don't return them right away, is that a sin?
他说这就是恼人的地方，尽管他不再是虔诚的天主教徒，不再相信天堂和地狱，他仍然发现自己在问：这有多坏？大罪？轻罪？坏到什么程度才算坏。例如，就在上周，他想办法推脱陪审团义务。大罪还是小罪？没有在24小时内回复电子邮件。他说这是小罪，但大到他会向写邮件的人撒谎，这当然是大罪。但他觉得这不如伤害别人的感情——如果不及时回复的话——那么大、那么坏。还有回电话的事，必须马上回。如果不马上回，那是罪吗？
Oh yeah, oh totally. It's more like even just screening phone calls I go through that because--
哦，是的，绝对是。甚至连筛选电话我都会经历这些，因为——
You worry that you may be sinning by screening phone calls?
你担心因为筛选电话而犯罪？
Well, because when somebody calls you, I feel like it's an honesty thing that if you're there, you should pick up. And I lately have been not answering. And I just screen the phone calls, and it's a little bit of a moral quandary for me. I talked it over with a couple of friends who suggested a compromise.
嗯，因为当有人给你打电话时，我觉得这涉及到诚实问题，如果你在的话，你应该接听。我最近一直不接。我只是筛选电话，这对我来说是个道德困境。我和几个朋友讨论过，他们建议折中一下。
What's the compromise?
什么折中方案？
To turn the volume down so that I can't hear. So I don't know who's calling me, I'm actually not being forced to decide whether I should answer the phone or not. So I'm at peace with myself again.
把音量调低，这样我就听不见了。所以我不知道是谁打来的，实际上我就不必被迫决定是否应该接电话。所以我内心又平静了。
Jim Nelson in New York City.
Jim Nelson，纽约市。
Act Five, Creating Your Own Moral Code. Eli had no problem deciding how bad is bad enough to count. Unfortunately for him, federal officials did not agree with his judgment about good and bad, and they threw him and his friends in prison for what they did as computer hackers. Did he learn a lesson from his time in the big house?
第五幕，建立你自己的道德准则。Eli在决定坏到什么程度才算坏时没有问题。不幸的是对他来说，联邦官员不同意他对好与坏的判断，他们因为他作为计算机黑客所做的事将他和他的朋友们送进了监狱。他在大牢里学到教训了吗？
It was so fun. I have to say I had fun. It was a good experience, and I don't regret going there actually.
太好玩了。我必须说我玩得很开心。那是一次很好的经历，我其实并不后悔去那里。
I think a lot of people are going to hear this and feel a certain horror. They're going to feel like people should be punished.
我想很多人听到这些会感到某种恐惧。他们会觉得人们应该受到惩罚。
Oh yeah, what I did was a bad thing, and I don't suggest anybody else do it because that would be wrong. I don't do anything illegal anymore.
哦，是的，我做的是件坏事，我不建议别人也这样做，因为那是错误的。我现在不做任何违法的事了。
Well, we started this program with three aspiring computer hackers who feared hell. This is the story of an accomplished computer hacker who does not fear hell. Starting in mid 1980's, Eli was a member of a crew of computer hackers called MOD. In the crew and online, Eli was known as Acid Phreak, that's phreak, P-H-R-E-A-K. Journalists from The Village Voice and Esquire magazine documented just how much MOD was able to do. It is entirely possible that no group American of hackers before or since has ever gotten as far in breaking into other people's computers. They infiltrated dozens of businesses and government networks.
嗯，我们以三位害怕下地狱的业余黑客开始了这期节目。这是一个不惧地狱的资深计算机黑客的故事。从1980年代中期开始，Eli是一个名叫MOD的计算机黑客组织成员。在组织和网络上，Eli被称为Acid Phreak，注意，Phreak，拼写是P-H-R-E-A-K。《村声》周刊和《时尚先生》杂志的记者记录了MOD到底有多厉害。在他们之前或之后，没有任何美国黑客组织在入侵他人计算机方面走得这么远。他们渗透了数十家企业和政府网络。
At one point, the reporters from Esquire asked them to demonstrate their skills by breaking into the White House computer system. And then, they watched them do it. But MOD's real love was not actually breaking into stuff like the White House. What they loved was trying to figure out the biggest, most sophisticated, complicated computer system in the world, which is the phone system. They hacked their way into the highest level computers that run the phone system for New York and New England, meaning they had the power to assign any services to any phone, listen to any phone, disconnected or create accounts, get unlisted phone numbers or bring the whole system down.
有一次，《时尚先生》的记者要求他们通过入侵白宫计算机系统来展示他们的技能。然后，他们看着他们完成了。但MOD真正的爱好并不是入侵白宫之类的东西。他们喜欢的是弄清楚世界上最大、最复杂、最精密计算机系统，也就是电话系统。他们黑进了管理纽约和新英格兰电话系统的高级计算机，这意味着他们有权为任何电话分配服务、窃听任何电话、断开连接或创建账户、获取未公开的电话号码，或者瘫痪整个系统。
Eli served six months in a minimum security prison and six months on home confinement. This interview was recorded a few years ago while he was still on home confinement in his parents house in Queens.
Eli在低安全级别监狱服刑六个月，并在家软禁了六个月。这次采访是几年前他还在皇后区父母家中软禁时录制的。
The prison I had to gone to was very relaxed. It was more like a fame camp. People who were known and people who were involved in high profile cases went there. That's what it was. I had a couple of really good friends there. Across from me, on the other side of my rooms, was a man they used to call the Condo King. And he lived in Massachusetts in a castle that was probably worth $5 million and had butlers and Roll-Royces and this and that. It was a real castle right on the water. And he taught me about real estate, which was the funny thing. So I learned real estate from him. I learned about stocks. I learned from the best, and it was such a great experience. It was like college all over again.
我去的监狱非常轻松。那更像是营地。知名人士和涉及高调案件的人都去了那里。就是这样。我在那里有几个非常好的朋友。我房间对面，是一个他们叫“公寓大王”的人。他住在马萨诸塞州的一座大概价值500万美元的城堡里，有管家、劳斯莱斯等等。那是真正的城堡，就在水边。他教我房地产知识，这真有趣。所以我从他那学到了房地产。我学到了股票。我从最好的地方学到了东西，那真是一次很棒的经历。就像重回大学一样。
The attitude there was that of camaraderie. Everybody there had this one thing in common, and that was that they looked for the shortest way possible to achieve what they wanted to achieve. And they all got there at some point, and they just felt a stroke of bad luck I suppose.
那里的态度是同志情谊。每个人在那里都有一个共同点，那就是他们都在寻找实现目标的捷径。他们都在某个时刻达到了目标，只是运气不好而已。
There were no losers there, that's for sure. Everybody there had achieved a very high level of success, very well known in whatever they did. I was friends with all the mobsters there, and they took care of me and stuff because I was from New York and I knew about Little Italy and Mulberry. And they were just impressed because I was the only hacker in this whole compound.
那里绝对没有失败者。那里的每个人都在他们所做的领域取得了非常高的成功，非常有名。我和那里的所有黑帮成员都是朋友，他们照顾我什么的，因为我来自纽约，我了解小意大利区和桑树街。他们印象深刻，因为我是整个监狱里唯一的黑客。
As the only hacker, Eli got a lot of job offers in prison.
作为唯一的黑客，Eli在监狱里得到了很多工作邀请。
Everything from obtaining credit cards to changing credit to-- yeah, changing credit was a big thing because-- I don't know if you know about this but-- every time these real estate guys get busted, their credit usually goes down the tubes. One big request I had was to change a lot of credit reports and stuff. But I didn't' do that and didn't take it seriously. I just told them, yeah it was possible, but you're not going to get it from me.
从获取信用卡到更改信用——是的，更改信用是一件大事，因为——我不知道你是否知道这个——每次这些房地产家伙被抓，他们的信用通常都会一落千丈。我收到的一个大请求是更改大量的信用报告什么的。但我没做，也没太当回事。我只是告诉他们，这确实可能，但你别想从我这儿得到。
And there were a lot of mobsters who wanted me to set up phone lines for them that couldn't be detected by the police and things like that. And again, well, it's possible, but I can't do that for you. But then again, if you were to ask me that and I was to do it, I wouldn't tell you anyway. So that's a question that's hard to answer.
而且有很多黑帮成员想让我为他们设置无法被警察检测到的电话线之类的。同样，嗯，这确实可能，但我不能为你做。但话说回来，如果你问我，而我真的做了，我也不会告诉你的。所以这是一个很难回答的问题。
Come into my domain. This is my room. As you can see, it's a typical teenager room.
进入我的领域。这是我的房间。如你所见，这是个典型的青少年房间。
Well, sort of typical. The bedroom he lived in during his six month home confinement was tiny, barely enough space for a bed, a desk and a bookshelf. There was a TV and VCR, two computers. Eli flipped on the stereo.
嗯，算是典型的吧。他在六个月软禁期间住的卧室非常小，几乎只能容下一张床、一张桌子和一个书架。有一台电视和录像机，两台电脑。Eli打开了音响。
I don't know. I guess I've got a lot of equipment around here. I've got a fax machine here. In my room, I've got five phone lines. I've got a two-line phone, but I've got everything else connected to computers or a fax. I've got three modems lying around. My computer is always on.
不知道。我想我这里有很多设备。我这里有一台传真机。在我的房间里，我有五条电话线。我有一部双线电话，但其他所有设备都连接到电脑或传真机上。我有三个闲置的调制解调器。我的电脑总是开着的。
There were cheesy Kung Fu movies on video. On Eli's CD player, old school rap, Nine Inch Nails, The Doors, Jimi Hendrix. Finally, he said, "Let me show you the good stuff." And he pulled out xeroxes of old spiral notebooks.
录像带里放着蹩脚的功夫片。Eli的CD机里放着老派说唱、九寸钉、门乐队、吉米·亨德里克斯。最后，他说：“让我给你看好东西。”他拿出了旧螺旋笔记本的复印件。
What was seized from me but they had to return back to me is my evidence examination report by the United Secret Service. Subject, Acid Phreak. These notes have basically all the systems I got into. Look, I have little sketches and diagrams of how things work, different protocols and networks, definitions. See, a lot of stuff was really good. I had stuff outside of the country, NASA.
从我这里缴获但后来不得不退还给我的，是美国特勤局的证据审查报告。主题，Acid Phreak。这些笔记基本涵盖了我进入的所有系统。看，我有工作原理的小草图和图表，不同的协议和网络，定义。看，很多东西真的很好。我有国外的资料，美国宇航局。
"The something defense," what is that?
“某某防御”，那是什么？
Government defense.
政府防御。
Yeah, that's a Washington number. McDonald's, since I had telenet, I had McDonald's accounts. If you were a McDonald's employee, I could raise your pay. So that way you'd get $15 an hour for shuffling burgers and stuff.
是的，那是华盛顿的号码。麦当劳，因为我有Telenet，我有麦当劳的账户。如果你是麦当劳员工，我可以提高你的工资。这样你搬运汉堡什么的每小时能拿15美元。
So did you decide just at random to help someone out?
那你决定随机帮助某人？
I didn't do it to anybody. I just wanted to know how. We did this from payphones. We'd have a line of payphones. We'd get into the computer, first liberate one phone, liberating meaning make it so that you don't need quarters for that payphone. You just pick up and dial like a regular house phone. So that way, we could make endless amount of phone calls without putting in quarters.
我没对任何人做过。我只是想知道原理。我们是在公用电话上做这些的。我们会排一列公用电话。我们会进入电脑，先解放一部电话，解放意味着让你不需要四分之一美元硬币就能使用那部公用电话。你直接拿起话筒就能像拨打普通家庭电话一样拨号。这样，我们就能无休止地打电话而不需要投币。
Next step was to get into the network, find a session that was already going and then knock them off while they were connected. And then sit there watching them. In other words, put us in the place of the computer they were going to connect to. So next time they'd try to log in, they would get our computer. And we'd type in, "login." And they'd put in their login account. Then we'd go, "password." The password. They'd say, OK, password, and they'd put their password in. All these things were already encoded in one key, so we could just hit one key, and it wouldn't look like we were typing it.
下一步是进入网络，找到一个正在进行的会话，然后在他们连接时把他们踢下线。然后坐在那里看着他们。换句话说，把我们放在他们要连接的电脑位置上。所以下次他们尝试登录时，他们会连到我们的电脑上。我们输入“登录”。他们输入他们的登录账户。然后我们输入“密码”。密码。他们会说，好的，密码，然后输入他们的密码。所有这些东西都编码在一个键里，所以我们只需要按一个键，看起来就不像我们在输入。
Login would just appear, whumph. Password, whumph.
登录界面就会出现，砰。密码，砰。
Yeah, we'd hit the password key, and the password would come out. And then we'd say, "login incorrect" and then disconnect from them. But we already got their login and password. And then when they reconnected, it would be the regular system, so they'd figure, hey, I made a mistake typing it in or something. And that's how we would get into accounts. It was funny.
是的，我们按密码键，密码就会出来。然后我们说“登录错误”，然后断开与他们的连接。但我们已经拿到了他们的登录名和密码。当他们重新连接时，那就是常规系统，所以他们会想，嘿，我输入错了什么的。这就是我们进入账户的方式。这很有趣。
You get into things that are good. You start targeting systems that are interesting. And then you start developing a collection. It's like baseball cards. I have NASA. I have NSA. I've got phone company computers. I've got [? Mizar ?]. I've got [? Cosmos. ?] I've got this, I've got that. McDonnell Douglas, [? Merriam Marietta, ?] TRW, CBI, TransUnion. What else can I get? You try to get the big names, so you start developing a collection.
你进入好东西。你开始针对有趣的系统。然后你开始收集。就像棒球卡。我有美国宇航局。我有国家安全局。我有电话公司的电脑。我有[? Mizar ?]。我有[? Cosmos ?]。我有这个，我有那个。麦道公司，[? Merriam Marietta ?]，TRW，CBI，TransUnion。我还能搞到什么？你试着搞到大牌，所以你开始收集。
Then, after a while, it became fun to look up famous people. Let's look up John Gotti's credit. Let's see what he owns. Let's look up Julia Roberts. Let's get her home phone number. Let's get this guy's home phone number. I'd go into payphones and stuff and hooking up. I would drive up to a payphone really quick and do what I had to do and leave really quick. That's when I really got into a movie.
然后，过了一段时间，查名人资料变得很有趣。让我们查查John Gotti的信用记录。看看他拥有什么。让我们查查Julia Roberts。获取她的家庭电话号码。获取这个家伙的家庭电话号码。我会开车去公用电话什么的，然后连线。我会很快开到公用电话旁，做完我必须做的事，然后很快离开。那是我真正进入电影状态的时候。
I felt like it was Mission Impossible , like that whole gang where it's like [SINGING MISSION IMPOSSIBLE THEME SONG]. And then we would all go out and hook up and everything. It was like, yeah, all right. I'm that black guy who does all this technical stuff. I can get into it. Let's go, let's go.
我觉得就像《碟中谍》，就像那个团伙，就像[唱着《碟中谍》主题曲]。然后我们都会出去连线什么的。感觉就像，是的，没问题。我是那个做所有技术工作的黑人。我可以搞定。我们走吧，走吧。
I felt like we should have walkie talkies and headsets and everything, and be like "OK, Blue, go do your thing on 5. Ready? 5, 4, 3. You're in, you're in." It was just amazing after a while. And we were just so excited we were getting all that stuff, and it was just a rush, the flow. Once you start going, you can't stop. You're just steamrolling one after the other. And the flow gets you going, and then, you're just like, yeah, we rule. We're it.
我觉得我们应该有对讲机和耳机什么的，就像“好的，蓝色，去5号机干活。准备好了吗？5，4，3。你进去了，你进去了。”一段时间后，这简直太不可思议了。我们当时太兴奋了，因为我们得到了所有那些东西，那简直是一阵冲动，一种流速。一旦你开始，就停不下来。你就像推土机一样一个接一个。那种流速让你不断前进，然后，你就像，是的，我们统治一切。我们就是一切。
If anything, it's striking how little they did with their power over computers. It was mostly pranks, making someone's phone line ring continuously for hours unstopping. Turning an enemy's home phone line into a pay phone line, so that when the guy picked up the home phone, it demanded that he deposit a quarter, which of course he could not do because it was just a regular phone. It was his home phone.
即便如此，令人震惊的是他们对电脑的使用权力做得有多少。那大多是恶作剧，让某人的电话线连续响几个小时不停。把敌人的家庭电话线变成公用电话线，这样当那家伙拿起电话时，它要求他投币，而他当然做不到，因为那只是普通电话。那是他的家庭电话。
They did call Julia Roberts once. They called Queen Elizabeth too. But there's an emptiness at the heart of a lot of these stories. Once you've got the queen mother on the phone, what do you say?
他们确实打过一次电话给Julia Roberts。他们也打给了伊丽莎白女王。但这些故事的核心有种空虚感。一旦你给女王妈妈打通了电话，你会说什么？
She's like, "Hello?" She's talking to us. And we don't know what to say. "Hi, we're calling from the United States," and this and that. And she knew what was up. She's like, "OK, hello." And then she said goodbye, and that was it. We didn't know what to say. What do you say to Queen Elizabeth. "Hi, so, you see that movie, True Lies ?" What do you say? The fun of it is finding the number.
她就像，“喂？”她在跟我们说话。而我们不知道该说什么。“嗨，我们从美国打来，”等等。她知道发生了什么。她就像，“好的，喂。”然后她说了再见，就那样。我们不知道该说什么。你对伊丽莎白女王说什么？“嗨，你看了那部电影《真实的谎言》吗？”你该说什么？乐趣在于找到号码。
Eli was thrown in prison for a relatively minor offense. It went like this. Some of the members of his crew broke into the computers that list everybody's credit ratings. They copied some credit reports, and they sold that information. Eli was named as a member of this conspiracy.
Eli因为相对较轻的罪行被送进监狱。事情是这样的。他团伙的一些成员入侵了列出每个人信用等级的电脑。他们复制了一些信用报告，并出售了这些信息。Eli被指控为这个阴谋的成员。
They said we abused our power, but we didn't abuse it at all. We did nothing compared to the things that could have been done. What we did was such a small thing in such a larger scheme of things. It's kind of depressing in a way. I mean there are so many things we could have done. We could have monitored Peter Lynch, and what's the next best investment for the day. And we'd make millions of dollars investing or shorting some stock. But we never did. Now we wonder why. We're like, damn. There are so many applications for this stuff. What happened? But then, we were like, "Ah, we were just kids."
他们说我们滥用了权力，但我们根本没滥用。和那些可能做出的事情相比，我们什么也没做。我们所做的在更大的范围内是如此渺小。从某种程度上看这真令人沮丧。我的意思是我们可以做很多事情。我们可以监控Peter Lynch，看看当天最好的投资是什么。我们可以赚几百万美元去投资或卖空某种股票。但我们从没做过。现在我们想知道为什么。我们就像，该死。这些东西有太多的应用了。发生了什么？但那时，我们就像，“啊，我们只是孩子。”
Then one time one of us got the Mad Magazine owner's phone number, and we called. At that time, he was going through some rough times or something. And we were calling him for about two weeks. And he was just so goofy. He was kind of crazy. And he was just really stressed or something. And we just kept calling him and calling him, and finally we started harassing him and harassing him. We made fun of him and laughed at him and called him Alfred E. Neuman and just ridicule him. And then he got so mad at us, and we used to keep calling and screwing around with him.
有一次我们拿到了《疯狂》杂志所有者的电话号码，我们打了过去。那时候，他正经历一些艰难时期什么的。我们给他打了大概两周电话。他真的很古怪。他有点疯。而且他压力很大或者别的什么。我们就一直打，一直打，最后我们开始骚扰他，骚扰他。我们取笑他，嘲笑他，叫他Alfred E. Neuman，只是嘲弄他。然后他被我们惹火了，我们经常继续打，整他。
And then one day, we read in the paper he died. The day after we had called him, he passes away. And we're there, like, yo, did we kill him? I hope not. And then they said he had some nervous breakdown and this and that. We were like, oh my god, I think we contributed to his demise there. We better not tell anybody this. But then, we realized there were probably other factors that contributed to it, not just a kid calling him on the phone. But since then, we stopped doing things like that because it was like, oh my god.
然后有一天，我们在报纸上读到他去世了。在我们给他打电话后的第二天，他就去世了。我们就在那，就像，哟，是我们杀了他吗？我希望没有。然后他们说他精神崩溃了什么的。我们就像，天哪，我想我们在他的死亡中起到了某种推波助澜的作用。我们最好别告诉任何人。但后来，我们意识到可能有其他因素导致了它，不仅仅是一个孩子给他打过电话。但从那以后，我们停止做那种事了，因为那简直是，天哪。
I don't destroy computers. I don't take them down. I don't delete information that shouldn't be deleted. I don't. I think there's something morally wrong if you affect a person personally and it's not only in his computer life but  in his personal life, his right to make a living. I think that's wrong. It's just a question of morality.
我不破坏电脑。我不瘫痪它们。我不删除不该删除的信息。我不会。我认为如果你在个人生活上，不仅仅是在他的电脑生活，而是在他的私人生活、他谋生的权利上影响了一个人，这是在道德上是错误的。我认为那是错的。这只是道德问题。
One thing about the computer world is that it's still relatively new, and hacking is still relatively new. So people in this world are still running across situations where no rules have been set about what's right and what's wrong. And in that situation, people have to create their own moral code. Eli's crew had its own particular code of behavior. For example, unlike most hackers, his crew did not share its information with other hackers.
计算机世界的一件事是它仍然相对较新，黑客行为也仍然相对较新。所以这个世界里的人们仍然会遇到没有任何规则规定什么是对、什么是错的情况。在这种情况下，人们必须建立自己的道德准则。Eli的团伙有其独特的行为准则。例如，与大多数黑客不同，他的团队不与其他黑客分享信息。
We had complete control over certain networks. We could have any system we wanted on that network. Any host was ours, but still you don't let it get out to other hacking groups and other hackers because if they don't know how to use it, they don't understand the power of it all. You can trust them. It's too much power for some people.
我们完全控制了某些网络。我们可以拥有那个网络上的任何系统。任何主机都是我们的，但你仍然不会让它外泄给其他黑客组织和其他黑客，因为如果他们不知道如何使用它，他们就不理解这一切的力量。你无法信任他们。这对某些人来说权力太大了。
Basically, it's like having a gun. Let's say it's the Wild West. You take it upon yourself to have a gun. You're responsible for it. If you give that to someone, you're responsible for that. So you don't give it out. If you want to shoot somebody's sister, somebody's wife or something, that's upon you. It's all a question of morality in my eyes. And if I know something, and it's of importance to somebody else, who's to tell me I can't sell it if I know it?
基本上，这就像拥有一把枪。假设这是狂野西部。你主动承担起拥有一把枪的责任。你对此负责。如果你把它交给某人，你就对此负责。所以你不把它交出去。如果你想射杀某人的姐妹，某人的妻子什么的，那是由你自己决定的。在我眼里，这一切都是道德问题。如果我知道某事，且它对其他人很重要，谁来告诉我，如果我知道它，我就不能卖掉它？
We're not evil people. We're good people at heart. There was a time when me and my friend Nynex Phreak, another guy in the group, we found a system that actually-- what it did was you could input a certain series of digits. It would take those digits and see if it was a credit card. So you could basically hack out credit card numbers just by guessing. Is this a credit card number? It would tell you if it was or not.
我们不是邪恶的人。我们内心是好人。有一次，我和我的朋友Nynex Phreak，组里的另一个人，我们发现了一个系统，它实际上——它的作用是你输入一系列数字。它会接收这些数字并检查它是否是信用卡。所以你可以基本上通过猜测来黑出信用卡号码。这是信用卡号码吗？它会告诉你是不是。
And we found that system. Finally, somebody wrote a program that would automatically do it, scan all night and get thousands of credit cards. And we were like, yo, this is no good. What if they start selling credit cards and stuff. We were like, this is no good, so we actually called the FBI and told them about it. I mean we didn't narc on anybody. We didn't say who wrote it or anything. We just said there's a system that isn't right that it's open like that. It was just getting ridiculous. So I was like, we have to put an end to this. And we did that, and we were like, we can't tell any hacker we did this. They'd be pissed. And we felt like that was right to do. That's kind of wrong.
我们发现了那个系统。最后，有人写了一个程序可以自动完成它，整晚扫描并获取数千张信用卡。我们就像，哟，这可不好。如果他们开始卖信用卡什么的怎么办。我们就像，这不好，所以我们实际上打了电话给FBI并告诉了他们这件事。我的意思是，我们没出卖任何人。我们没说谁写的程序之类的。我们只是说有一个系统不该这样开放。这简直太荒谬了。所以我就想，我们必须结束它。我们确实做了，我们就像，我们不能告诉任何黑客我们做了这件事。他们会火大的。我们觉得这样做是对的。那样做简直是错的。
In fact, when I was visiting Eli, he was facing a daily question of right and wrong when it came to his own home confinement. The prison system monitored his movements with this electronic device that was riveted to a strap around his ankle. The device sent signals to a computer about his whereabouts, and then that computer called another computer at the department of corrections. It used a phone line to do that. Hacking this computer was pretty easy work. It was clear how to do it, but Eli chose not to do it. He was going straight, he said, not because he thought hacking was wrong, and not because he was scared of getting caught. He was just tired of hacking.
事实上，我拜访Eli时，他正面临着关于他自己软禁的日常正确与错误的问题。监狱系统用这个铆在他脚踝带子上的电子设备监控他的行踪。该设备向电脑发送关于他所在位置的信号，然后该电脑再致电矫正部门的另一台电脑。它使用电话线来做这件事。黑入这台电脑很容易。方法很明确，但Eli选择了不做。他说，他要改邪归正，不是因为他认为黑客行为是错的，也不是因为他害怕被抓。他只是厌倦了黑客行为。
We had lists and lists of computers and no time to do it in. It just got to the point where it was such a large burden. It was like, oh, we have to this one. Oh, there's another one we have to do. It got to hundreds and hundreds. And finally, it's not even fun anymore. It's such a rush to get it when you initially get it, but then it gets to be boring.
我们有列不完的电脑列表，却没时间去做。它只是到了一个地步，负担太大了。就像，哦，我们必须做这一个。哦，还有另一个我们得做。它有成百上千个。最后，它甚至不再有趣了。最初得到它时那种冲动很强烈，但后来它变得很无聊。
Here in Chicago, I've talked to members of big street gangs who've told me the same thing as those. They were quitting the gang not because they thought it was wrong to be in a gang or because their pasts were catching up with them. They were quitting because they were just tired of having the same night over and over again, hanging out on the streets, seeing the same people, doing the same stuff. That's the thing about being bad people don't talk about much. It gets boring.
在这里，在芝加哥，我和大型街头帮派的成员谈过，他们告诉我同样的感受。他们离开帮派不是因为他们认为参与帮派是错的，也不是因为他们的过去正在追上他们。他们离开是因为他们厌倦了反复经历同一个夜晚，在街上闲逛，看着同样的人，做着同样的事。这就是做坏人的那种人不太会谈论的事情。它变得很无聊。
I've just burned myself out, I think. I just got to that point. Everybody gets burned out if they have a little too much of everything.
我想我只是把自己搞累了。我只是到了那个阶段。如果每个人都有点太多的一切，都会感到精疲力竭。
Today, three years after that interview, Eli is a manager of information security on Wall Street.
今天，距离那次采访三年后，Eli是华尔街的一名信息安全经理。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Our senior editor is Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack [? Hitt ?], Margy [? Rockland, ?] and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Emily Hampford, Rachel Howard, and Alex Blumberg. To buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380.
嗯，我们的节目今天由Nancy Updike和我本人制作，Alix Spiegel和Julie Snyder协助。我们的高级编辑是Paul Tough。特约编辑Jack [? Hitt ?]，Margy [? Rockland ?]和顾问Sarah Vowell。Emily Hampford、Rachel Howard和Alex Blumberg提供制作帮助。要购买本节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，312-832-3380。312-832-3380。
Our email address, [email protected] This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的电子邮箱是[email protected]。本节目由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia, who says this about his years before public radio.
WBEZ管理监督由Torey Malatia先生负责，他谈到了自己在公共广播电台之前的那些年。
Oh yeah, what I did was a bad thing, and I don't suggest anybody else do it because that would be wrong.
哦，是的，我做的是件坏事，我不建议别人也这样做，因为那是错误的。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life . Until then, I'll dedicate this song to you.
我是Ira Glass，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。在那之前，我把这首歌献给你们。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。